[Music]
on this thursday night britain's prime
minister relents and resigns
boris johnson bows to the revolt within
his own party and i want you to know how
sad i am his rise and dramatic
fall the decision on a forensic audit of
the afn and the battle to end the
bureaucracy of indian status cards from
the basketball courts to a russian
courtroom wnba star brittany griner
enters a plea on drug charges
and the ultimate in pay parking and good
luck in finding anybody in canada is
going to help the russian plane
indefinitely grounded on canadian soil
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie in
politics no one is remotely
indispensable and our brilliant and
darwinian system will produce another
leader equally committed to taking this
country forward through tough times
a long anticipated resignation delivered
today by boris johnson in front of a mob
of onlookers many booing the outgoing
british prime minister
good evening thanks for joining us boris
johnson's scandal-ridden tenure atop the
british government is in its final
chapter he announced today he will step
down only staying on as prime minister
until his successor is chosen he leaves
behind a divisive legacy which we'll
have more on in a moment but we begin
tonight outside 10 downing street with
our europe bureau chief crystal
gomensing krystal
colleen there's still a good number of
reporters and cameras set up here
outside of the prime minister's official
residence in office it was right here
this afternoon at 12 30 that we saw
boris johnson do something out of
character he gave in
and resigned
on a regular day there might only be a
few people hanging around the gates to
number 10 downing street but this
is no ordinary day i want you to know
how sad i am
to be giving up
the best job in the world
that thems the breaks in typical boris
johnson fashion his resignation address
included a quality one-liner but lacked
contrition
never did he take responsibility for his
actions which led to his party pushing
him out it's painful and not to be able
to see through so many ideas and
projects myself
but as we've seen
at westminster
the herd instinct is powerful when the
herd moves it moves he's a buffoon he's
an idiot and you can't trust him it's
like dealing with 11 year old children
who just say it wasn't me it wasn't me
johnson is a polarizing figure beloved
by some hated by others until now his
personality worked in favor of the party
he drove the tories to its biggest
majority since 1987 and got brexit done
as promised severing ties between the
united kingdom and the european union
this was a prime minister that left
office with a sense of injustice a sense
in which he felt that he had somehow
been hard done by and that the mandate
he'd been given in 2019 have been
undermined by his own political party
and by the mainstream media for years
johnson has been besieged by scandal and
dogged by biting headlines the final
scandal surrounding his appointment of
chris pincher as deputy chief whip
despite allegations of harassment
johnson was told of those allegations
two years earlier but then said he
forgot about them reaction to johnson's
resignation has come from around the
world michelle barnier the former eu
brexit negotiator tweeted the departure
of boris johnson opens up a new page in
relations adding it could be more
constructive and respectful
in ukraine johnson has many fans he was
the first western leader to visit in
april and has been a staunch supporter
vladimir zelinski wrote on his telegram
channel all ukrainians were saddened by
the news of the resignation of the
leader of the conservative party
the pressure is now off johnson but the
work is just getting started for the
conservative party it must start the
process to select a new leader and then
the tories have to find a way to unite
and govern
colleen crystal gomezing in london
thanks crystal
johnson's divisive leadership is already
sparking calls from within his party for
his immediate departure with many
pointing to the controversy and ridicule
that has plagued him throughout his
political career redmond shannon takes a
look at the rise and fall of a man who
never let convention get in the way of
ambition
during his eight years as london's bike
riding mayor it was an open secret boris
johnson had ambitions to eventually get
inside 10 downing street
when the momentous brexit referendum
opened up the job johnson lost out to
theresa may but he was ready to pounce
again when she failed to get the uk out
of the european union boris johnson is
elected
he promised mps and voters he'd get
brexit done
and he did signing off an eu exit deal
which is still contentious and
unresolved you must stay at home in the
early stages of the covert 19 pandemic
he was accused of hesitating on
lockdowns and dismissing the risks i
must continue my self-isolation he ended
up in intensive care with the virus
before overseeing the uk's quick vaccine
rollout but it will be his actions
during lockdowns that will define his
term in office those parties inside
downing street all the guidelines were
observed not according to police johnson
and others in government were fined for
breaking the very rules they had made
most of his mps held their noses at
other controversies too
until this week when johnson's claims of
ignorance about allegations of
inappropriate behavior against his
deputy whip were exposed as false they
were prepared to forgive him
you know so much but i think that was as
far as they were concerned unforgivable
and just like that the prime minister
who is considering three terms in office
is out after just three years redmond
shannon global news london
disqualified conservative party
candidate patrick brown is fighting back
by launching an appeal but experts say
it will be an uphill battle because of
party rules and treatment by the courts
meanwhile calls are increasing even from
rival candidates for the party to shed
more light on the allegations against
brown abigail beeman reports
patrick brown tapped high profile lawyer
marie hennen best known for successfully
defending gian gomeshi in a notice of
appeal to the conservative party she
writes brown has engaged in absolutely
no misconduct calling the process
kafkaesque she asks the leadership
committee to keep all documents and
records including communications with
members of the pierre polyeff campaign
relating to brown
both the polyeff camp and the party deny
complaints came from the top rival no
other leadership campaigns were involved
in the allegations the party president
tells global news there are multiple
allegations and at least one but not all
came from within the brown campaign we
want to respect mr brown's rights in
terms of engaging legal counsel and
pursuing this as a canadian citizen and
we will be responding directly to mr
brown
through legal counsel before undertaking
any further comment but a road to appeal
will be uphill perhaps the biggest
hindrance are the leadership rules brown
agreed to all decisions of the
leadership election organizing committee
are final and not subject to internal
appeal or judicial review and political
experts say courts generally rule they
don't have jurisdiction in the internal
affairs of political parties a court
challenge is unlikely to produce a
successful result for for mayor brown in
terms of getting him back into the race
but if uh chaos and destruction and
embarrassment are his goals it is quite
vital
jean charese camp is calling for more
transparency the concern is that this
will tarnish the image of the party in
the eyes of voters it's a it's a scandal
it's something that people don't need to
see at this time when we're trying to
get a positive message across that the
conservative party is a government in
waiting the liberals have now weighed in
calling on the commissioner of canada
elections to quote follow the money and
investigate not just brown but whether
the party has benefited from any of his
alleged actions via financial windfall
or otherwise abigail beeman global news
ottawa
the assembly of first nations annual
meeting in vancouver is coming to an end
a session overshadowed by the group's
leadership crisis the national chief
says she was suspended for trying to
investigate claims of corruption but
today a resolution after a vote a
forensic audit of afn finances will go
ahead some in attendance are celebrating
this review others aren't pleased it's
taken up so much time as nito garcia
reports many chiefs hoped other issues
would get more attention
emergency draft resolution number one
the resolution to begin a forensic
review of the afn's finances dating back
at least a decade is approved has been
adopted with 75 percent of the votes
during the debate some chiefs voicing
concerns about the audit's cost and
whether it would spark a freeze on
federal funding others say it took away
from critical matters like education
climate change and child welfare
probably the most frustrating times of
my life because i was sent here to do a
specific job and
i haven't been able to fulfill my duties
to my community b.c cook pior chief judy
wilson has long been trying to draw
attention to another key issue that
affects every member at these meetings
some of our elders waited their lifetime
to get their status membership and they
never did indian status cards are
critical pieces of government id that
have to be renewed every 10 years under
what wilson says is an extremely onerous
process which she and nearly 20 thousand
others have signed a petition to end i
might wait up to eight years to get a
five year renewal she says red tape and
understaffed banned offices are slowing
the process and many can't afford to
travel to a federal government renewal
office so this is my card it looks like
this unlike many who spent years proving
their ancestry through historical
records to get theirs brittany epple was
born with one it feels like a sense of
control and
when you look back in the history of why
we even have status cards to begin with
it's because of the indian act and the
indian act was created for the purpose
of assimilation
indigenous services canada says the
renewals are in line with other
documents used to confirm identities at
banks airports and borders and that it's
actively working to improve the process
we are currently
testing out a a fully digital
application process and it is live now
in 14 service kiosks across the country
they shouldn't have to renew them
because our status number
stays with us from cradle to death nithu
garcia global news vancouver
an american athlete heads to a russian
courtroom brittany griner's plea coming
up plus
hey
what are you gonna do
nice college boy yeah
morning the incomparable james kahn
ukraine is celebrating a symbolic and
strategic victory in the war with russia
the blue and yellow flag being raised on
snake island in the black sea after it
was recaptured from russian forces the
tiny island controls the sea lanes to
russia's port of odessa in its nightly
video addressed to the nation vladimir
zelinski said on wednesday western arms
including heavy artillery and rocket
systems are starting to make a
difference on the battlefield
american basketball star brittany
grinder pleaded guilty to drug charges
in a moscow court today leaving her
facing up to 10 years in prison if
convicted the 31 year old has been in
custody since february when she was
detained after cannabis oil was
allegedly found in her luggage in a
russian airport the trial of the
two-time olympic champion started last
week but was delayed the white house
said u.s president joe biden called
griner's wife to say he's doing all he
can to have her released as soon as
possible
hundreds of people were chased through
the streets of pamplona spain today as
the running of the bulls returned no one
was gored in the race but six people
were injured including an american who
suffered a broken arm despite its
controversy the festival is incredibly
popular drawing tens of thousands of
visitors from around the world
oscar-nominated actor james khan has
died
well when business will have to suffer
all right hey listen do me a favor tom
no more advice on how to patch things up
just help me win please all right
khan was best known for his roles in
misery and his portrayal of sonny
corleone in the godfather khan starred
in a string of films from the mid-1960s
through the early 80s before quitting
acting he ended his retirement in 1990
playing writer paul sheldon in misery
and endeared himself to younger
audiences as the curmudgeonly dad in elf
james khan was 82.
spending criticism ahead following a
foster care company's money trail
you're watching global national
[Music]
all week long we've been taking you
inside the operations of an ontario
company which for four decades ran
foster care and group homes for
vulnerable youth and which still
operates three group homes it's called
connor homes a private company run by
the conner family that profits from the
kids in its care with the help of
taxpayer money but it's how connor
holmes handled that money that has
sparked criticism and how little some
say was left for the kids it was meant
to serve carolyn jarvis reports in a
global news aptn investigation
the finances of connor homes and its
affiliate businesses are a dizzying maze
numbered companies layered upon numbered
companies all owned by members of the
connor family bob at the top his son
sean running the day-to-day operations
connor holmes states its foster care and
group homes help kids in need
but follow the money and you'll see some
of the connors also helped themselves
the money that exchanges hands is huge
there are some people getting very very
rich in 2013 sean agreed in family court
for his divorce that he earned an
estimated 200 000 a year from his foster
care company his ex-wife also alleging
he engaged in extremely aggressive
accounting techniques
listing payments for a boat and two
trailers similar to these as corporate
expenses if we look at the financial
statements from 2008 we asked two
independent forensic accountants to
review the divorce file including matt
mcguire i would not expect in this line
of business that you would be expensing
a boat and recreational trailers sean
denies the allegations saying the
trailers were indeed business expenses
used in lieu of hotel rooms while other
items may not have actually been claimed
by his accountant it smells funny
according to a list of corporate
expenses he prepared for his accountant
sean also spent nearly 67 thousand
dollars on hotels restaurants and
entertainment from 2007 to 2009. he
defends it was for rewarding foster
parents and workers and that he had to
promote his company to government
agencies
but sean didn't have any government
contracts his sole client was his
father's company
here's how it works bob connor is the
president and co-owner of a numbered
company known as connor homes which
until recently was licensed as a foster
care agency and which still runs three
group homes
shawn operates a second numbered company
which acted as a middleman between his
father and some of the foster parents
who took in kids what sorts of things do
you need to run a business where all you
do is push a contract to somebody else
right not a boat
according to financial data from 2018
foster care agencies in ontario like
connor holmes received an average of 173
dollars a day per child from children's
aid societies
while connor holmes paid foster parents
58 dollars per day for each child as
stated in a contract from that same year
there's a whole bunch of people getting
in the middle taking a cut that's right
we tried to speak
with bob and sean connor hello i'm
looking for bob i'll find out a few
months thanks but despite multiple
attempts to reach them he's saying no
but thank you very much they declined to
appear on camera
in a statement sean conner said the
parent company connor holmes had its
foster care funding reviewed and audited
annually so this is a real problem
experts say this is but an example of
what happens when the province allows
profit to be a driver
instead of quality of care take the
profit out of the system it would render
care a social process as opposed to an
economic process take the price tag of
kids carolyn jarvis joins us now from
toronto carolyn i understand you've been
getting a ton of response to this week's
series
oh colleen we received more than a
hundred emails and countless comments on
social media from people who either
lived in the system or worked in the
system and said this
this was me this was my experience and
not just people who worked at connor
homes but from right across the country
people who said the system is broken and
in urgent need of reform okay so what is
the ontario government saying about this
issue might they reconsider for-profit
foster care and group homes well great
question that's exactly what we wanted
to ask but neither premier ford nor the
minister on this file marylee fullerton
would sit down to speak with us premier
ford did say during the recent election
campaign that child welfare would be one
of his quote key focuses once he resumed
office but his government has
continually sidestepped the issue of
for-profit care meanwhile two opposition
parties have made calls to end it
carolyn jarvis in toronto thanks carolyn
thank you
next no-fly zone why this massive cargo
plane hasn't seen the skies since
february
at more than one thousand dollars a day
the tarmac at toronto pearson
international airport has become one of
the most expensive parking lots in the
world a russian cargo plane has been
racking up those fees since february
after canada declared it could no longer
fly mike joley explains
february 27th was a noteworthy day for
this ansonov an-124 cargo plane it had
just delivered 3 million coveted rapid
antigens hess to toronto's pearson
airport and after the russian army
destroyed the antonov 225 the largest
cargo plane in the world the an-124
became number one by default
oh and that was also the day this
particular plane was grounded
indefinitely in toronto
you see three days after the invasion
canada like many other countries closed
its airspace to russian aircraft a
ministry of transport spokesperson says
this measure is in effect until further
notice so the massive antonov can
technically leave the country it just
can't fly
this thing's a big paperweight now
aviation lawyer bill clark was hired by
an unnamed canadian cargo company
looking to help ukraine by keeping the
plane out of the war despite russian
claims it's a commercial aircraft
baloney
we even use them for military purposes
what the distinction is
that they're trying to make is that
they're not registered as military
aircraft but they're utilized all the
time clark makes no bones about his role
it's to money the waters using the law
if the no-fly zone is lifted he'll argue
the plane hasn't been maintained or the
russian owner volga denepper hasn't paid
its bills
and parking at pearson isn't cheap
1065.60
per day for a total of 138 thousand
dollars
and counting
the one thing clark won't do
work for the russians
i have had overtures through
two different foreign countries
for our legal firm to act on behalf of
the russian operator and we said kiss
off
and good luck in finding anybody in
canada that's going to help you so if
you're driving by pearson airport and
spot the largest cargo plane in the
world don't stop in the hopes of seeing
it take off
it could be here a while mike drew like
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
thursday night i'm colleen christie
tonight's york canada is puerto mulan
historic parks windmill completed back
in
1708. thanks for watching sophie louie
will be at the anchor desk tomorrow good
night